franz josef fleece has his hands full in
the customs museum in hobb Kishen on
Germany's border with friends the
retired customs officer is a volunteer
curator of the exhibition in the old
border house
there aren't any border controls anymore
and today the museum mostly serves as a
symbol of good neighborliness
but now the cross-border friendship
faces a new challenge the coronavirus
crisis bus I never thought I'd see
Germans having something against the
French just because the coronavirus was
a bigger problem in France never have
believed that this would happen again
French people faced insults and were
accused of spreading the virus before
the borders were closed again in March
like at this bridge a German authority
had declared the neighboring French
region a risk area only those who worked
on the other side were allowed to
continue crossing the border flees says
he understands why it had to close what
can you do
of course the virus doesn't stop at any
border in the world it's the people who
come across with the virus who spread it
it hit home low man hard he's French and
commutes to work in Germany then the
border was closed overnight without
notice he was allowed to cross the
border but some Germans suddenly began
to treat him as a threat
the mock assault when he's get told that
we are now no longer wanted that really
hurts why it's not our fault everyone
knows it comes from China could just as
easily have been the Germans who got it
worse it's not our fault that hurt me
the mayor of the German border town of
gasps Haim also has French roots as his
name suggests Misha Olivo read the
reports of cross-border commuters from
France who were insulted on the streets
by people who told them to go back to
their Corona country in Germany's
Francophile state of silent of all
places franco-german friendship was
being put to the test
the crisis has shown that this
friendship may not be as stable as we
imagined and wanted it to be and I
believe that we have work to do to
establish a feeling at least among the
locals that this partnership is
important for Europe that's a he offed
alone leave all publicly criticized the
behavior of his fellow Sol and errs and
now faces criticism himself yeah I was
seriously accused of fake news here
because many didn't want what I said to
be true but I think it was important to
say loud and clear that we have a
problem
now that the border is finally open
again the German wants to set an example
by visiting his French counterpart in
neighboring kremlings Alec Emmet is
experiencing the friendship crisis from
the French side he worries that the
German reaction could leave scars it's
created a climate of distrust in a way
our history has caught up with us again
the extremism suddenly comes out in one
way or another the looming War Memorial
testifies to the history of a border
region that was fought over in the wars
between the two countries the two mayors
say it serves as a warning for
politicians on both sides
they say that careless statements made
the crisis worse
the political rhetoric also influences
people's actions and how they deal with
the fear that's around them and so if
you tell them for weeks that you have to
protect those Islanders from the French
and of course people take that into
consideration and maybe take a rational
action that's what we've seen here the
crisis has given the old sign of the
European friendship bridge in hobb
Kishin new meaning flees the former
customs officer would like it to be put
back in its old place you can't break a
friendship as strong as that between
Germany and France that has grown over
decades with nonsense like this I cannot
imagine that this has caused permanent
damage absolutely not in any case the
coronavirus border closure will find a
place in franz josef please little
museum as a new chapter of franco-german
border history